depuis 2011 la guerre civile en syrie a
fait plus de 250 mille morts et a
provoqué le déplacement de plus de
quatre millions de réfugiés
mais qui sont les forces en présence sur
le terrain pour simplifier on peut dire
qu'il y en a quatre d'abord l'homme fort
de damas le président bachar al assad
qui règne sur le pays avec un pouvoir
autoritaire sans partage face à lui il a
les rebelles une sorte d'agglomération
de groupe un peu différent par exemple
l' armée syrienne libre mais également
des groupes islamistes et même le front
à nostra qui est affiliée au groupe
terroriste al qaïda ensuite il ya les
kurdes qui voudrait étendre ce qu'ils
appellent leur entité territoriale le
kurdistan
enfin bien sûr il y à l'état islamique
qui lui tente de s'élargir de plus en
plus à partir de son fief de jaca mais
qui soutient qui dans la région assad
est proche des chiites donc forcément il
reçoit l'appui de pays comme l'iran ou
encore du hezbollah qui est basé au
liban les rebelles celle inverse ils
sont soutenus par les sunnites et
d'autres pays comme la turquie la
jordanie et l'arabie saoudite qui
fournissent argent et armement les
curieux peuvent compter sur un coup de
main de leurs confrères turcs et
irakiens
enfin l'état islamique peut compter
parmi ses rangs plus de 30 mille
combattants qui viennent de l'étranger
et qui sont les grands joueurs
internationaux présents également
bien sûr on peut commencer avec la
russie de vladimir poutine indéfectible
allié de bachar al assad qui depuis le
début tente de combattre les rebelles
qui sont hostiles à assad
c'est aussi probablement le dernier
allié de moscou dans la région qui
fortement dominé par l'influencé
américaine des américains parlons-en
justement ils sont présents là également
avec leur coalition dont fait notamment
partie le canada
ils veulent chasser à ça du pouvoir et
bien sûr donner un coup de pouce aux
rebelles qui sont présents bref la syrie
est devenue un terrain de jeu de plus en
plus minés et on ne voit pas comment la
situation pourrait se résoudre à court
ou moyen terme